the days are getting shorter the sun is
rising later and yet another summer has
passed without resolution to the small
boats crisis
first light and we spot a recently
abandoned dinghy the disregarded clothes
and a blanket are still wet
we counted at least 10 life jackets the
people who wore them have now moved on
but they've left behind communities
which whilst largely empathetic appear
exhausted divided and frustrated after
the uk committed nearly 200 million
pounds to the french over the last six
years to help break the cycle
mike golding has lived here for more
than 40 years and says it's become
normal to see migrants arriving on the
beaches
you've got to feel sympathy for them but
you've got to draw the line and
how many are you going to live into the
country and what you're going to do
about it to stop them the french are not
going to do anything
they want rid of them as much as we
don't want them are you kind of resigned
to the way things are yeah very much so
nowadays you just take it for granted
they're going to come
and that's it really nothing we can do
at this level but others can't contain
their anger and are turning their
frustrations directly onto the migrants
lawbreakers shouts one woman
they're coming in now to land
can you tell me why you're here
another local resident kim rai films as
she challenges new arrivals on the beach
at dungeness a few weeks ago was france
not a nice country to live in
it's organized it's organized crime it's
divisive as well
we went to see kim and her husband
graham who say they want to make it
clear they welcome what they call
genuine refugees but admit their
attitude to asylum seekers and in
particular economic migrants is hostile
young men
getting off a boat and strutting up the
shingle wearing nike trainers carrying
smartphones
i'm sorry but that's not a refugee
oh are you pleased to be here of course
we are if you lived through this every
day
if you were listening to the helicopters
going up the police sirens
and that's why i'm angry i feel very
protective of this community nobody
knows who those people are they don't
know who they are they don't know where
they've come from the longer it goes on
the greater the chance is that something
nasty will happen somebody coming up
that beach tooled up with ak-47s
that's not the way everyone views the
migrants
terry preston has lived on this coast
for most of his life it's very divisive
and it certainly divided the community
we need to treat these people with
compassion and justice and of course
there's got to be an immigration system
we can't in this small island take
everyone who comes but there's got to be
a compassionate way in which that's
dealt with
the government says it's determined to
tackle the rise in channel crossings but
without a significant shift in policies
they're likely to remain the backdrop to
the lives of those who live in these
coastal communities lisa holland sky
news kent